Jeff D'Andria: Welcome back. This is the first time I've done that kind of an exercise, so I'm really,
Jeff D'Andria: I don't have a previous experience on best way to process this, but I'm really curious what y'all came up with, if anyone would like to show, maybe?
Jeff D'Andria: What they came up with, but just curious what that was like for you all, and…
Jeff D'Andria: What'd you come up with?
Jeff D'Andria: Anyone wanna hop on first?
Shawn Lin: Oh, I can share mine.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah.
Shawn Lin: I'll make sure I'm actually clean.
Shawn Lin: So… well, this was the job I was looking at.
Shawn Lin: And, well, the first thing I noticed was…
Shawn Lin: Be successful, you have to be able to work efficiently on your own, and as part of a team.
Jeff D'Andria: That's a good catch. Really good catch.
Shawn Lin: And then… well, looking through, like, what's the must-haves, like, SQL experience, Python's experience…
Shawn Lin: So, in my review, I pretty much just put… Understanding of programming, so…
Shawn Lin: for my example, I've worked on several different projects, primarily in Python, and, like, I have experience in working with AI and, like, libraries associated with AI with my
Shawn Lin: material assistance project.
Shawn Lin: Which is a team project, and it's…
Shawn Lin: I didn't put it on here because I forgot, but it's essentially to help professors at CSULB with their, like, planning of their course materials.
Jeff D'Andria: Nice.
Shawn Lin: Yeah.
Shawn Lin: And then I have Team Player here.
Shawn Lin: So…
Shawn Lin: A lot of the projects that I've worked on involved a team, and I've been part of different competitions, like competitive programming and hackathon.
Shawn Lin: And, like, one of my proudest moments was when I participated in a competitive programming competition, and we actually performed the best the school had ever seen in, like, I think it was, like, a 3-4 year span, almost.
Jeff D'Andria: That's that kind of context that's super helpful, like, to…
Jeff D'Andria: Saying, like, 3 or 4 years, or, you know, whatever's the more honest one.
Jeff D'Andria: that's, like, that context that really helps. And then I really like that you said a team on the first one, that you talked about being on a team.
Jeff D'Andria: Kinda not mentioning that in the beginning, like, mentioning it toward the end of the bullet.
Jeff D'Andria: It's just a weird thing recruiters have said… heard from many, like, once you start, but it was on a… you were on a team in the beginning, it… for some reason, it's kind of like, it turns them off. They want to hear about what you did. Mention the team thing at the end of the sentence, so I like that.
Jeff D'Andria: Rossly.
Shawn Lin: I just kept the closer thing. So this…
Shawn Lin: in the making of a bus delay predictor, and this was a class project. I also worked alongside a team across a 3-month span. We got kind of busy with schoolwork, finals, stuff like that, but I really spent a lot of time trying to finish the machine learning model, and then
Shawn Lin: Following up on my teammates and asking them about, like, making a simple front end for, like, the project.
Shawn Lin: To make it easier to actually access the model, rather than, like, having to run on your own machine, we can maybe, like, host it, something like that.
Jeff D'Andria: So you continued the project.
Jeff D'Andria: It sounds like.
Jeff D'Andria: On your own.
Shawn Lin: gap.
Shawn Lin: Yeah, pretty much, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: That's a great call-out. That kind of, like, shows that closer piece, and then…
Jeff D'Andria: You could argue that that turns into kind of a passion project, if you kept running on your own time, if you wanted to create a passion project section, or use those words.
Shawn Lin: For the bonus segment, I mean, I read through the description, this job is pretty much intended to help, like, businesses
Shawn Lin: it was, like, help businesses predict through data how to, like, better improve their businesses, essentially, like, more profitable and more efficient. So…
Shawn Lin: I'm excited about the project because I spend a lot of time on YouTube just watching business contents, like.
Shawn Lin: why recently Spirit Airlines failed as a company, like, stuff like that. And, like, watching these videos, you see a lot of trends, like, stuff like, maybe the company didn't adapt, like, adapt fast enough in time, and, like, a lot of that is based off of data and, like.
Shawn Lin: Yeah, I'm really excited to work on, like, a project that might involve that.
Jeff D'Andria: Pierce, how does this fit into your niche, would you say, in this?
Shawn Lin: So, for my niche, I…
Shawn Lin: I really like data-driven things. A lot of target roles that I want are, like, data scientists, machine learning.
Shawn Lin: I think…
Shawn Lin: I mean, through this program so far, I've learned that I actually really don't like making new projects, but I like…
Shawn Lin: Improving, kind of, projects.
Shawn Lin: I explained it.
Shawn Lin: I think… in the discussion I had with the AI, they said, I really enjoy
Shawn Lin: What is it? I enjoyed?
Shawn Lin: I mean, the best I can put it is, like, I, like, enjoy improving projects, or improving models rather than making models, if that makes sense.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, and then I want to hear from another student, but before we leave, like…
Jeff D'Andria: So you're into data, they're about that, too. So if there's any kind of, like, real-world examples, so we can do a demonstrated interest, which you're, I think, starting to do with your
Jeff D'Andria: What you were sharing, which is great, but anywhere… and then if you could…
Jeff D'Andria: demonstrate the interest always is going to be good, and then, if you get that word love in there, like, is there anything you love in your life that's resonating with this kind of company and the problem they're solving? I'd be curious what kind of life experiences come to mind, and that could be an emblem or something to throw in.
Shawn Lin: Me too.
Sathya Narayanan: And, Jeff, from a time check point of view, is it okay if I…
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, oh, sure.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah, concluding, and then if anybody wants to stay back and share, and others want to listen, we can do one more. Does that sound okay?
Jeff D'Andria: 100%.
Sathya Narayanan: Trying to find it, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Super last thing, the emblem thing, the human touching, it could be computer science related for, say, the software engineer audience in the room. It could be. It doesn't have to…
Jeff D'Andria: not be, you know? But… just want to give you that permission to color outside the lines and let it be from life, not necessarily school and CS.